Metta as we know it,
atoms, stars and galaxies,
planets and trees,
rocks and us.
This matter accounts for less
than 5% of the known universe,
about 25% is dark matter
and 70% dark energy,
both of which are invisible.
This is kind of strange because it
suggests that everything we experience is
really only a tiny fraction of reality,
but it gets worse.
We really have no clue what dark
matter and energy are or how they work.
We are pretty sure they exist though.
So what do we know?
Dark matter is the stuff that
makes it possible for Gannett
says to exist. When we calculated why
the universe is structured the way it is,
it quickly became clear that there's
just not enough normal matter.
The gravity of the visible matter is
not strong enough to form galaxies and
complex structures.
The stars would more likely be scattered
all over the place and not form
galaxies. So we know there is
something else inside and around them.
Something that doesn't emit or
reflects light, something dark.
But besides being able to calculate
the existence of dark matter,
we can see it kind of places with a high
concentration of dark matter bend light
passing nearby so we know
there's something there
that interacts with gravity.
Right now we have more ideas about what
dark energy is not than what it is we
know dark matter is not just clouds of
normal matter without stars because it
would have met particles we could detect.
Dark matter is not anti matter because
anti-matter produces unique gamma rays
when it reacts with normal matter.
Dark matter is also not
made up of black holes,
very compact objects that vine
the effect their surroundings.
While dark matter seems to be
scattered all over the place.
Basically we only know
three things for sure. One,
something is out there too.
It interacts with gravity.
Three varies.
A lot of it dark matter is probably
made up of a complicated exotic particle
that doesn't interact with light
and matter in a way we expect,
but right now we just don't know.
Dark energy is even more strange
and mysterious. We can't detect it.
We can't measure it and we can't taste it,
but we do see its effects very clearly.
In 1929 Edwin Hubble examined how the
wavelength of light emitted by distant
galaxies shifts towards the red end
of the electromagnetic spectrum.
As it travels through space,
he found that fainter,
more distant galaxies showed
a large degree of red shift.
Closer galaxies,
not so much Hubble determined that
this was because universe itself is
expanding.
The red shift occurs because the wave
lengths of light are stretched as the
universe expands.
More recent discoveries have shown
that the expansion of the universe is
accelerating.
Before that,
it was thought that the pull of gravity
would cause the expansion to either slow
down or even retract and collapse
in on itself. At some point,
space doesn't change its
properties as it expands.
There's just more of this new space
is constantly created everywhere.
Galaxies are tight bound clusters
of stuff held together by gravity,
so we don't experience this
expansion in our daily lives,
but we see it everywhere around us.
Wherever there is empty space in the
universe, more is forming every second.
So dark energy seems to be some kind of
energy intrinsic to empty space and a g
that is stronger than anything else we
know and the keeps getting stronger as
time passes by empty space has more energy
than everything else in the universe
combined.
We have multiple ideas about
what dark energy might be.
One idea is that dark
energy is not a thing,
but just a property of space.
Empty space is not nothing.
It has its own energy. It can generate
more space and is quite active,
so as the universe expands,
it could be that just more and more
space appears to fill the gaps and this
leads to a faster expanding universe.
This idea is close to an
idea that Einstein had back
in 1917 of a concept of a
cosmological constant or force that
counteracted the force of gravity.
The only problem is that when we try
to calculate the amount of this energy,
the result was so wrong and with
that it only added to the confusion.
Another idea is that empty
space is actually full of
temporary virtual particles
that spontaneously and continually formed
from nothing and then disappear into
nothing.
Again,
the energy from those particles could
be dark energy or maybe dark Kenji is an
unknown kind of dynamic energy fluid
or field which permeates the entire
universe but somehow has the opposite
effect on the universe than normal energy
and matter.
But if it exists,
we don't know how and where
or how we could detect it.
So there are still a lot
of questions to answer.
Our theories about dark matter and dark
energy are still just that theories.
On the one hand, this is kind of
frustrating. On the other hand,
this is frontier science
making it very exciting.
It shows us that no matter how much
we feel we're on top of things,
we're still very much apes
with smartphones on a tiny
fragile island in space
looking into the sky,
wondering how our universe works.
There is so much left to
learn and that is awesome.
This video is supported by the
Australian Academy of Science,
which promotes and supports
excellence in science.
Learn more about this topic and others
like is [inaudible] dot org dot a u.
It was a blast to work with them,
so go check out their site.
Our videos are also made possible by your
support on patrion.com if you want to
support us and become part
of the [inaudible] bird army,
check out our patrion page.